[Music]
hello and welcome to the Android
fireside chats we have a lot of content
today we're gonna get through that first
and see if we can get to the questions
next if we could get to the next slide
because we're ready for some questions
so we do actually have one question to
start it off if we could go to that one
as well
so someone asked online on the Twitter
thread why is it called a fireside chat
if there is no fire I thought this was a
pretty good question so the answer to
that would be
all right so warm yourselves by the fire
we're gonna ask some questions you're
gonna ask some questions we're gonna try
to answer those questions let me
so we pre-rolled some questions online
it was interesting to see what people
were thinking online so we have some of
those will interleave those questions
with questions from the audience I will
show you how that works in a second
first let's introduce the panel and chet
haase Android toolkit team Dave Burke I
get blamed for those things
Steph cuff person I work on the
developer experience Oh Maggie yeah I
work on the graphics in cuffing rush I
work on playing and snaps I think I'm
hack born I managed the framework team
I'm Xavier jacory I work on the couch
team we have also a bunch of other
people from the engineering team to my
stage right here so if one of these
people can't answer it then maybe one of
the people in the audience can't answer
it either so let me show you how this is
going to work we have a couple of
questions to kick it off and then we'll
kick it out to the audience from there
so first of all what's an exciting
feature that you're working on for the
next release romant you want to take
that one no I don't okay that's that's a
really good example to keep in mind we
do not answer questions about future
development kind of a policy thing that
we have I would say 90% of the questions
that I got on the Twitter thread when I
asked where about future development so
that makes it easy we don't have to
answer those this is going really well
yeah yeah
so we'll be done in the next two minutes
all right let's ask a more real question
I'll toss this to Roman again will
Android architecture components be a
de-facto architecture choice with
continuous Google support that's like
continuous builds except for support so
very long answer yes more more seriously
we listen you were asking us to have an
opinion about Gothic architecture for
many years we did not have one you could
do whatever you wanted you can still do
whatever you want but we have a solution
that's our solution we're going to
support it we have to in we have more
and more libraries around it we have the
communication tons of talks so if you
like it or if you don't even know what
option architecture you want to use go
with that one so there you go
that's an example in fact it was a real
quick
and kind of a real answer as well I
would invite everybody in the audience
to ask a question there are two
microphones down here we were curious
how long it would take people to get to
the microphones so it's gonna be kind of
a Hunger Games kind of thing going on so
please come up to the mics and ask a
question if people in the audience don't
ask questions I have some here so we can
certainly do that I see someone walking
up right there why don't we start with
that one go ahead the mic the mic is too
tall for me so following up the question
about architecture components
I remember Dianne posting online saying
that like you know look we gave you
activity we gave you a content provider
we gave you all these things
that's the agnostic platform you can do
whatever you want with it like we're not
gonna impose any choices on you I'm sure
there are other people on the Android
team who agreed with her
I wonder what what Diane and those those
other people might think about
architecture components is this like a
perversion of what like their their
vision of Android or is this like or is
this something that like okay well I
understand why some people might need it
but if you want to do things weirdly you
can you know you can do that like what's
what's the was there a debate about
architecture components so the answer is
that basic it all still holds true as
far as the core platform is concerned so
you can think of like and when I say I'm
as a framework team it's really the core
platform this is a stuff that's that's
you know shipped on the device that that
is like defines what you can do with the
device and we want to keep that still
generic you know not enforcing any
particular model on applications where
it doesn't make sense because we want to
have a lot of flexibility for
applications to to you know do new
things in the array on things like kind
of stuff the architecture components are
basically a layer on top that you know
it's very different because it's in the
support library so it can evolve very
rapidly with the applications it can
change and break because it's not gonna
break applications when those changes
happen so we're basically putting a new
layer on top of the platform that gives
our very strong position on how we think
applications should be developed which
will probably actually evolve very much
over time as the world changes yes
and let's face it you know every few
years and she has decided there's a new
and better way of architectural things
we had MVC than MVP the nemi vici we
discard mvi the other day on Twitter I
have no idea what it is I think you're
just making that up at this point
so yeah I'm showing this year's it will
have evolved to something else I also
want to tell a funny story about that
post that you referred to of Diane's
because we were talking about it
backstage like three minutes ago I had a
few minutes ago how many people here
have read that posts of Diane's see I
told you so so many people have read
that post and I remember you posted it
and then it got like a hundred and
twenty-five comments and I remember I
walked back to Diane's office and I said
Diane dude do we need to have an opinion
and she said I think we might need to so
it's a it was been great to get that
feedback and it really helped us figure
out how to evolve Thanks whatever here
hi there a question on media formats
codex is there anything beyond the HDR
vp9 that's new impeded you can talk
about something come closer to the mic
maybe it's really the acoustic very
difficult very great audio video codecs
new formats and P that you can talk
about beyond the vp9 HDR support you
could X in P I remember no we added a
bunch of Bluetooth codecs like AAC and L
back to go beyond SBC I don't think we
added any codecs and P I'm looking down
phone-a-friend this is what I called to
the Android team yeah everyone's shaking
their head I don't think we added any
new codecs and cake I think the
consensus is no thanks hey first of all
I just wanted to thank you all for all
your hard work then and everyone
actually so it's been a great i/o and I
think you've made a lot of progress and
just listening to the community it's
been awesome
my question is gonna be about testing I
know it's gonna really ill shock her
okay it's a question for you
somehow I so it's it's question
obviously for chat at the Android you
know two days ago
Chet actually had two slides on testing
one was something about fluent
assertions the other had a picture of a
drink with a straw in it it was about
the ability to mock final static things
in the android framework yep and then
remain made an awesome comment he's like
Chet looks confused you know
and I actually I was also confused I
don't know why you would want you know
to kind of you know not maybe give that
ability but highlight is there one of
the important things in testing because
later in the testing talk and you know
and we actually talked about the fact
that that's kind of undesirable we don't
want to have people do that so could we
get some comment on like what is our
official stance on being actually using
that very powerful and dangerous
approach to testing what's your opinion
so official stance is probably a little
strong but I would say there are
probably more there are more better
approaches to testing such as the other
stuff that I talked about the the ADSL
stuff that's in jetpack now espresso
testing frameworks that actually do
things correctly however you heard from
the audience's response to the ability
to mock the framework that sometimes
developers need for whatever purpose the
ability to do that and the framework is
really about providing the capabilities
that you need for your particular
situation so by providing the ability to
mock the framework specific methods more
easily we're saying here is a facility
if it's important to you and necessary
for what you're doing it may not be the
right general approach overall but if
it's a piece that people feel they need
there's a bit of plumbing for you I
don't know if anybody else had a
different take on this that helped I
mean I guess I could add a little bit
there's there's some
there's like philosophically like not
having you know finals and stats and
stuff is fine you know the issue is
within the platform we have those you
know in the api's and for good reason
right yeah so but so that means that if
you do want to mock something in the in
the in the in the platform anywhere you
need to be able to do that and so like
we had actually discussion about like
getting these into mockito and there was
like no no no this is wrong you
shouldn't do this but you know like
we've kind of reached the agreement that
like well in this case it actually is
you know like it makes sense this is
like something we need to do so that's
that's why for the freight word
developers all its for it well not for
framework developers but for anyone
who's writing tests where they want to
mock out framework api's okay like you
have you know like a context that you're
the window manager from and you want to
mock out the window manager object to
see if you the correct calls happen on
it all right thanks a lot
Thanks what's your current thinking
around Android tablets
they like them you still see it as like
a device type within the base platform
or are you like winding it down and
chucking it over to Chrome OS I'm
missing can if you can get closer they
might think like do you still see it as
a base part of the platform or or deep
happy chatter over to Chrome OS guys
because it's kind of like we're getting
mixed signals then it's like with Chrome
OS they don't they support Android but a
tempra Android first they have a
different system UI so it's like is
there gonna be a tablet version of the
new P overview swipe thingy whatever I
guess
[Applause]
so from a platform perspective we
support tablets you know you know we we
have some Sonico we still support
tablets from Google pixel perspective
which is a product team they've been
focused on through the crossover form
factors so tablets crossing over with
laptops so that pixel look for example
once you have a hard keyboard Chrome OS
is a really nice operating system and so
what they've done is they brought chrome
as you know brought Android apps running
with the in Chrome OS and to us you know
purist on the Android team it's actually
a nice thing because it's the same apps
that run on a Chromebook with Android as
on a tablet and so insofar as it's
helping Android ecosystem have better
large screen landscape size in this case
apps it's all helping you like it helps
tablets too but yeah that's that's sort
of status the as far as a platform is
concerned we support tablets there's a
lot of Android tablets you look like
you're not done with all right we're not
happy with my answer it just seems
Chromebooks are still focus on web first
yes they support Android but they're not
like they don't put it first so it's
like what's the story from the
developers side okay I bought a pixel
see you don't support anymore but it's
like should we be buying Chromebooks and
like detachable Chromebooks foot it to
vape on or I mean you should buy
whatever spice you think it's good for
you to buy I use a pixel book by the way
I love it I think it's good and I've run
Android apps on it
that's me personally but I think
everyone should pick whatever product
they want from from our perspective you
know as a platform operating system
provider it's important that android
supports tablets and has good tablet
apps and that's what we focus on all
right folks
so I went to one of those sessions which
was the best practices for kind of the
current state of Android and you guys
went over the current way to do
constraint layouts and databases but I
was wondering you guys didn't really go
over what kind of you think we should be
doing for networking I know a few years
ago you guys were pushing volley really
hard but now I feel like there's volley
and retrofit and 15 other libraries and
I know what kind of depends on what your
use cases but if you were gonna say for
someone starting off what would you
recommend for the networking manager for
us to use an Android app recommend for
what for networking like making network
requests just a regular get request rep
someone someone in the peanut gallery
says retrofit good you want to have a
vote on that yes okay
yeah volley was the right thing for some
things at the time I think that there
are probably other more evolved
libraries out there that might be the
right solution and I think all libraries
do non-overlapping things so I I don't
think there's an exact match but they
said retrofit I certainly hear a lot of
good things about that like what one of
the there we go one of the things that
we're doing coincidental with the
architecture components but it's it's
not necessarily the same thing is that
when there's a good library out there
that we didn't happen to build we're
happy to recommend it that goes for
retrofit it goes for things like Picasso
for image loading Glide as well whatever
the thing is like if that's a good
library why should we reinvent that
thing in this case
all right all right maybe not retrofit
okay
[Applause]
are we done did you plan that I can add
we've been walking around and several
people I've have talked with have asked
if we can recommend more libraries
specifically outside of Google the ones
created by the community which that we
think work best and so I think that's
been great question and great advice
it's always been our intention with
jetpack to have an opinion about the
best way to do development because
several of you have said that saves time
you don't have to look at a bunch of
things or six as Jonathan always tells
me so I think it's it's been great
feedback Thanks sir is this close enough
yeah so a lot of the examples we've seen
for code during i/o not not close enough
a lot of the examples we've seen for
code during i/o have been Kotlin code
and I guess a question that I kind of
have is what's the long term things that
developers can expect they have a large
code base that's still in Java right let
me make sure the question was what
should developers expect if they have a
code base in Java programming language
like long term support from some so when
we when we invest it in Kotlin we knew
that was going to be an investment for
the long term so we're completely
committed to the language we also knew
and we invested in Kotlin day whenever
it was May 17th that it meant that we
were doubling down on all of our
languages and a lot of you have also
said that we needed to do more to
support the existing languages we had so
the way we saw it was we're not choosing
a new language we're investing in all of
our languages and in fact you can see
that in C++ we've launched NDK build C
make we've significantly improved that
NDK we launched the new C++ profiler
where we here the tool chain in the Java
programming languages we added Java 8
Java dot time is my personal favorite
and you should expect to see us continue
to invest in our languages it's really
important with such a large ecosystem
to support the ecosystem where it is at
the same time we've seen a tremendous
interest in Kotlin I think we talked
about some of the statistics and so like
28 of the top 100 apps 35% of Pro
developers it's had 6x growth in one
year so if you haven't looked at the
language we do think it's a good idea to
take a look but hopefully that helps in
select question in Twitter you are
saying that sway took us so long to
support another language because you
know the community has been asking for
different languages over the years and
it's been 10 years since Android
launched but we wanted to make sure that
whichever one we picked we would support
truly and correctly without dropping the
other one so we took our time we think
we made the right choice and we're going
to keep working on all three languages
that we support today I can tell this
app wants to say something so I'm gonna
toss a tools question over to them so
are there any plans for tools for build
speed profiling and optimizing I think
the context of the question was not can
you make to build faster but if they see
their build is taking a long time as
there are their tools or their
approaches that they can take to find
out what it is that's taking time so
that they can optimize it yes yeah we
see a lot of developers having a lot of
issues not being able to make that bill
faster and we did really want to help
there there's already a lot of resources
that you can use greater has Bill scans
that allow you to really get a lot of
insight into your build so you can
definitely use that but to realize that
having something integrated in studio
would be extremely useful so it's
definitely something we're considering
so I downloaded the Android P beta and
having a good time on it but my question
is white girl removed the clear-all on
the overview tab yes I asked that exact
question to the team about five or six
weeks ago and they're just they sighed
at me like and are they over there
oh that's a lair yeah it seems here hey
hey team hey team I told you so there
are there are two answers one is you
know Android is managing the memory you
know as well as you can you don't need
to swipe things away for Android to be
able to reclaim that memory in order to
be able to run other things the second
answer is yeah sorry about that well
we're looking at bring it back I can
tell you I have a bill that's after beta
one on my phone and I can proudly tell
you there's a clear old button on it so
it's coming back weeks so in 2014 I was
at the Moscone Center and asked you guys
a question if you were gonna keep
maintaining eclipse and I'm really glad
that you were not I'm 100% on the
Android studio wagon now I still worry
about built-ins which was one of the
questions that I had then but my
question to you guys is if what are the
what are the warts that you wish you
could redo from Android 1.0 so if you
could do Android 1.0 again what would
you change
oh so many things
the UI Tokita graphics pipeline I did
some of that applications right settings
I've often thought that designing api's
is building future regret I have never
yet created an API that I haven't
regretted something about in the future
I believe that they ran really fast they
I was not there at the time at the time
and therefore they were able to get it
out the door and now we have time to
actually fix some of those warts what we
can't do is remove methods and break
applications right so we would certainly
we have been improving things hopefully
and introducing new facilities and make
things better but we can't actually get
rid of some of the things that we regret
because we don't want to break the apps
that are depending on it so there's that
little bit of stuff that we can't quite
totally fix but we can improve other
things along the way yeah there's
there's there's a number of things that
you find just like we did 10 years ago
and like today are like oh my gosh that
is not scaling like one of the ones that
really stands out is that broadcast
we've gone through I our initial
decision to say like by default when you
send the broadcast it just goes to any
manifest receiver that wants to receive
it was a really bad decision and we kind
of we've learned this like over the last
few years as we've seen on devices like
more and more applications waking up
when just random things happening so we
have been going through this really
painful process with the background
researchers and all that kind of stuff
to try to get control of that again this
is a good time to file a bug report
because I've noticed on the on my bill
that when I changed between cell and
Wi-Fi it's slowing down a little bit
there's a little bit of Jack which I
know is broadcast because a network
change so Tim Murray I'm gonna fix that
book okay sound team one on one they're
moved to the app bundle style
optimization much earlier like the
version code management the multi-apk
starting at the build time it would
impose was just a lot of burden to put
on developers like you and really
excited that we're removing action
hi hi can you guys hear me
yes deeply jarring to see myself on that
screen hi so I've been doing Android
development for a while now and I've
really loved you know over the past few
iOS your guys's continued investment and
improving tooling and you know
supporting Kotlin is a first-class
language creating architecture
components this year at i/o we've also
heard a lot about flutter which I
understand to be the kind of
cross-platform mobile SDK what are you
all see in the future of these two
platforms in terms of Google's
investment like well once the plant the
other do we all need to learn Dart
what's the kind of five-year ten-year
view of that right so Google is a big
company we do a lot of things and as you
can see in the keynotes we explore the
future we have tons of experiments
flutter is an exploration of
cross-platform development and we're
excited because you know the Android
platform is a place where both
instrument teams and excellent team can
build this kind of exploration in
experiments the rich recently reached
beta and will you know we're watching
and we're waiting for the feedback from
developers so yeah so we're excited that
so much is happening on the Android
platform Thanks hi
so Android is now 10 years old and my
question is what happens when the first
developer certificates start to expire
when sorry when the developer
certificates start to expire do you have
like a mechanism how to rotate the keys
we'll follow up after so I always know
what is happening confidence confidence
inspiring that you guys so yes we are
obviously aware of this sound there were
guidance back then to use certificates
with long explorations like 30 years
which from a security best practices
point of view in retrospect another
thing we probably would do differently
better support for key rotations so I
think as you can see in the OSP code
there is some work towards we've had
some previous experiments with key sets
and now there's some more work going on
with new apk formats to support this
better in the future but it's still
work-in-progress but isn't the something
is actively being worked on yeah I
thought you were gonna say Android is 10
now what happens when it turns into a
teenager exactly I didn't want to get
into that one yes hi guys love your work
recyclerview is awesome does happen up
recyclerview is quite awesome thanks but
there's still a few places in the
platform where you still need to use
base adapters like ListView
spinners I think there's some remote
views that might use it and a little
slices sorry remote views yeah and alert
dialog I was just wondering if you guys
see that as a problem or if you want to
expand the awesomeness of recycler view
to more places we are certainly continue
to work on recycler view to integrate
more of what people need in that
component we don't want it to be a
kitchen sink of all things but it is
certainly possible to expand it into
more use cases that make sense for it I
don't know if somebody over there wants
to take it yeah Adam Adam UI toolkit
team so yeah I think that right now one
of the biggest things that kind of
impedes doing more of the integration of
recyclerview with some of the other
stuff in the framework is exactly some
of what Chet was saying earlier which is
that we can't do a lot of really key
changes to some of the stuff in the
framework there without breaking apps
and recyclerview is a conscious effort
to break from some of those existing
api's at the time so those are
directly one-to-one compatible so the
stuff that's in the framework right now
is still going to be there
in order to support the existing app
ecosystem but as we start building new
things I would expect to see a lot more
things built on top of recyclerview and
other jetpack libraries like that Thanks
all right can you hear me closer is good
so it looks like there is a shift
towards single activity applications I
was wondering to get some background on
the decisions behind that and maybe the
when you should use a single activity
application versus multi activity
application sure did you hear that
single single activity applications yeah
this is this is I well I'm gonna be the
first as I you know I don't have a
strong opinion either way I'm but we
definitely um you know as the UI
experience have gotten more
sophisticated it's definitely clear that
like you know like trying to like do
seamless transitions and all the things
you want to do between activities does
it doesn't it really doesn't really work
very well and there's really no need you
can think of activities as basically the
only place you really need activities is
where you need main entry points into
your application right and so once
you're in the application whether you
use activity fragments or whatever else
is kind of irrelevant to the operating
system and we are leaning heavily on
fragments with all the new the new you
know notion of navigation mala notte
concepts so that's are there any memory
million management concerns with
activity lenders having everything in
one activity very memory management I
don't I'm not profile your app
most of the stuff that you're building
at that point should be based on some of
the other lifecycle events as things are
coming and going is you're adding and
removing components from that single
container so the shutdown process should
be pretty similar whether that's a
separate activity or whether that's
another fragment thanks hi there so this
is close enough right my question is
about the new digital well being in
Android P so that was presented in the
keynote this option of actually defining
a limiter in time for usage of
particular apps so I was wondering
because they're already on the Play
Store for some years some apps that
actually offer this functionality like
did you did you guys base this idea for
those features based on AB suggesting or
some research particular some psychology
research or something like that and is
there is there any API that third-party
apps can just use to contribute to this
digital well-being idea and operating
system yeah I mean there's some great
apps on the Play Store you know not just
for this but also like headspace and
calm and sort of like a bigger area of
wellness we we what we've done has
basically created some low-level system
API to do things that you couldn't
ordinarily do in an app like we've
turned the screen grayscale or we
disabled app launcher icons and we were
also giving hooks for app developers to
have deep links into their app to
provide more information I haven't
looked so close to their system a few
guys to explain what all you could do on
top of them but then I just wanted to
thoroughly
if you want to help out with the mission
of digital wellness read up on the docs
for how notifications and do not disturb
mode work together so for example posts
notifications with enough metadata that
the user can use their ways and do not
disturb mode to say oh starred contacts
get through or certain apps get through
you populate all that information you
give the user more ability to safely
enter the Do Not Disturb modes that we
provide knowing that they're not going
to miss important stuff another way you
can work with do not disturb mode to
help the user manage their space is to
actually respect it right so you can
actually see what the state of the
device is and maybe this now is not the
right time to try to get the users
attention right so there are ways that
you can already work with and all those
ideas are already in the platform we've
we've tuned them up a little bit for P
but most of this stuff has been in there
since we introduced do not disturb and
then improved it with channels and oh so
look at those api's put those data on
the notifications to be able to
interoperate as best you can with the Do
Not Disturb feature we've already got
thank you just a follow-up question if
if if I'm interested in somehow
contributing with ideas or like working
together in in this area it will be
really cool if I have a contact some
kind of contact I can refer to services
you jumped from version 12 to 15 what
happened in between
Hotels jump from 12 to 14 on their
floors we just wanted to go one better I
I don't know the story behind that
versioning Google Play services
I think the release it just started
overlap we were testing a bunch of
experiments and we decided that we
should just snow pop forward to the
latest release for all users as opposed
to maintaining a bunch of experiments
nothing hidden in there it was three
better thanks yes okay is a sample yeah
okay so in our company our goal is to
build an apk with a list size so the
users we in third world countries
or like developing countries they don't
have to spend more data to download the
apk
so when last year you guys really
chuckling we didn't shift because we
read that coupling will increase the apk
size so we're trying to save even if
it's like 100k in the Africa side so how
are you going to address that life is it
still the same case if I try to move the
coupling with my epic aside increase
that's a probably a good question for
Ben and bran Kallstrom and jeffrey van
gogh are a team so our eight is our new
shrinker and so we added copeland
specific optimizations to make the code
smaller and we can actually do quite a
bit of things that you couldn't do in
Java because we have richer information
about your code when you're coding in
Kotlin we just started and already is
still experimental but I encourage you
to take a look at RAF and see if it
helps your case can I try out all right
right now is that an oh yeah it's
experimental feature in Android studio
3.2 and there's talks on how to opt into
that
so if you'd like to try the new alright
compiler just download the latest
preview of Android studio 3 - thank you
thanks
first off excellent work on Android pee
everyone as a follow-up question about
the clear-all notification why is the
clock on the wrong side actually they
start side because if you're an LTR
everything flips over I don't know why I
reach for the microphone I didn't really
want to know this is I mean this this
comes from the display cutout stuff that
we see coming from OEM as we know we
need to distribute things from one side
of the status part of the other some of
us have kind of always been a little
uncomfortable about the asymmetry of the
status bar like then the most neutral
state is everything kind of like on the
right hand side again the end hand side
so by moving the clock over not only are
we able to create a consistent
experience across Android devices
irrespective of whether they have an
unbroken top edge of the display panel
but we can bring just a little more
balance to it overall I will I'll point
out too that if you prefer it on the
right side just take your phone and turn
it around it's 180 degrees it works
perfectly every time
but then the notch would be on the
bottom well there's other issues I'm
just saying I as a personal anecdote
when we first moved the clock over I was
like ah what are we doing why and then I
think about seven or eight days later I
was like somebody came up to me said are
you still working worried about the
clock I'm like no it's fine
so you get you get used to it really
quickly yes yes we use features such as
Android and apropos okay can you hear me
yes all right so we use features such as
android enterprise and safety net but we
have a lot of customers with users in
China and so we wanted to know if
there's any guidance you can provide for
helping those users then I'm only
getting that cuz nobody knows for China
it's it's complicated
right I'm not gonna Google as limited
access to their servers though you know
all the whole issue so I don't have a
good answer for you for that do for
China other than it is something that
make myself and a few others here think
an awful lot about and the shortest
answer is it's complicated
but we're not necessarily giving up on
it because it is a problem that we
recognize there's an awful lot of
developers that need to deal with that
market and we need to do more I'm not
sure what that means in terms of
specifics but it is something that's on
my mind
thank you thanks probably time for a
couple more questions we are running out
of time we'll get to as many as we can
yes hello I noticed some stylistic
differences between the AOSP android p
version and the version on pixels which
we saw throughout io namely like rounded
corners versus square corners and some
font choices I was wondering what the
motivation behind that was
sure I'll take this one too up there
they're small touches I mean you just
said yourself we're talking about fonts
colors rounded corners functionally we
try to keep those devices as there are
those those targets as close as possible
because if it's you know good for pixel
it's good for everybody but we do have
you know we want to put a little Google
touch on things that we're putting
inside a box that's got a nice big
Google logo on it so we use the Google
typeface in activities and we've got
some rounded corners and different color
choices just a little bit of a little
bit of pain yes with the whole Java
lawsuit and court ruling
how is it affecting Android what's what
should we expect on developing a great
operating system and that continues to
be our focus great answer okay next
question I was told to wrap this thing
up I did have one more important one
from the Twitter thread that I'll end
this thing on I'm sorry we couldn't get
to all of your questions we would like
to do someone did ask online when will
Google officially support Kotlin lestor
may 17th 2007 teen so I think I think
that's it thank you
[Music]